ce matin dans le territoire de belfort
le péage de fontaine était bloquée par
les manifestants
le passage ne sauverait qu'une fois
toutes les 10 minutes pour préparer ce
blocage une centaine d'individus se sont
réunis dès 7 heures sur le parking d'un
hypermarché était derrière
là c'est le peuple qui se lève il faut
vraiment que le cema qu'on fasse quelque
chose là on peut plus vivre on est pris
à la gorge
il faut qu'on rachète des voitures mais
avec quoi nous fait des efforts tout le
temps on les paye ses taxes mais l'on
peut que ça a eu de faire des efforts et
ça a eu de montrer que ils ont été
dignes d'être au gouvernement qui
baissent leurs salaires aussi pour
montrer qu'ils nous entendent
certains ont bloqué l'accès au centre
commercial quand d'autres ont mené
l'opération escargot sur l'a36
provoquant une quinzaine de kilomètres
de bouchons pourtant la plupart des
automobilistes pris au piège ont apporté
leur soutien au gilet jaune
quelque part ils ont raison aussi dans
la marre de payer pour rien où passe
l'argent voilà tout ce que j'ai à dire
moi je soutiens de tout coeur seulement
j'aimerais bien rentrer hier matin sur
la route à vesoul entre 700 et 800
véhicules se sont réunis si la hausse du
prix des carburants a été le déclencheur
les raisons de la colère des gilet jaune
vont au delà
moi j'ai une maison je me demande chez
pour la garder ce que je dis note de gaz
qui n'arrête pas de qui vont copier vous
montez donc ça veut dire des notes
contient pas ce qui va arriver bientôt
sept troll un peu plus un peu plus on
est surtaxé c'est ça ma commission l'air
surtaxés il faut arrêter les gens ils
galèrent tous à pourvoir faire la fin du
mois un gars qui vivent avec le salaire
est bien lors de ce rassemblement à
vesoul
un automobiliste a été interpellé par la
police pour avoir giflé deux
manifestants deux semaines après avoir
connu la première manifestation des
gilet jaune en france il fallait s'y
attendre
dole était complètement bloquée et pour
ne pas consommer plus d'essence à la
pompe
ces manifestantes ont décidé de venir un
de chevaux
non
à besançon cet après midi les motards
ont rejoint les automobilistes pour
bloquer l'autoroute
aucune interpellation n'est à déplorer
mais le ton est parfois monté entre
gilet jaune et automobilistes pressés on
consomme plus belle les amis désunie au
final auprès du nivôse
ça a marché lentement un seul exemple
dans toute l'histoire de l'humanité
d'une manifestation qu'a servi à quelque
chose
malgré quelques agitations un seul
accident léger a été relevée c'est le
mot d'ordre en fait la sécurité et à la
sécurité la communication et la légalité
c'est les trois points clés du mouvement
en franche comté
plus de dix mille personnes ont
manifesté